ciao oggi mi piace colore giallo non so
se si è notata da questa cosa ma perché
mi piace colore giallo c'è un motivo ed
eseguite
però questo è l'effetto di z non c'entra
una mazza l'abbia facciamo una finta
gente che mi davi sono video su pokémon
lessio pikachu è arrivato finalmente il
rito supporto non lesivo pikachu che
sarà un po diverso da quello di marco la
nintendo mi ha inviato non solo tornano
le sue pikachu ma visto che mi vogliono
un sacco bene mi hanno infilato proprio
la console
la nintendo switch limited edition che è
veramente bene e già è veramente gialla
esca togliamo all'inter nave nemica
scatola troviamo la console con i giochi
con come vi ho detto prima che sono
questi ce la faccio vedere da vicino
perché lì non si vede niente questa è la
console e questi sono ufficio iphone ti
caccio xi i vari cosi per giocare e fare
le cose
i cavi ma volevo porre la nostra
attenzione su questo sì ma sbagliamo
effetto sonoro quello la grandissima è
irreprensibile pokémon plus che cos'è la
focol las e giochi con alla stessa
funzione dei giochi con normali
ovviamente ottimizzata per pokémon che
se la metti tutti puoi muovere con
questo che l'analogico e poi giocherà
poco non direttamente con questo tra
l'altro ogni poco forse non fare
dovrebbe avere il mio all'interno perché
se lo schiacci qua
esatto perché ogni poche con il plus
all'interno cia minimo cioè quando tu
entri nel gioco poi sbloccare subito
perché è all'interno e non solo poi
infilarci dentro i tuoi pokémon e
portate in giro ogni volta che mai dire
mai la tua nonna vaiano nel nonna senti
che cosa trovavo che fai sentire che c'è
il pokémon bello e tornano dice bravo
adesso vai a mangiare però ciancio
allemande troviamo questo podio
quindi ragazzi per rendere il video un
po più carino ancora ho deciso di
invitare uno special guest che si
intende un sacco di pokémon
allora adesso tu mi dici chi è il
53esimo pokémon nel facile prima
generazione bite sparrow giusto era
proprio lui
allora questo è pokémon let's go pikachu
tu hai siccome hai giocato spesso a
pokémon sa esattamente di cosa stiamo
parlando
oggi andremo a ribattere le palestre tu
che palestra bhatti quanti chili fai col
col manubrio
io voglio la verità zio non sono un
grande intenditore perché quando io ero
piccolino cir ai game boy capito adesso
giochiamo in tv hanno fatto un salto di
qualità non proprio el ovvero la racchia
grafica vuoi esatto boy sono passati a
questo comunque questo è lo stesso gioco
che c'era sul game boy solo che l'hanno
rifatto e hanno fatto hanno aggiunto un
sacco di cose nessuno proviamo si può
anche giocare in due e questa cosa io
non l'ho mai provata quindi sono
curiosissimo di vedere come funziona da
quando avevo 5 anni che gioco a pokémon
perché io avevo 5 anni quando è uscito
pokemon giallo tra l'altro e tu sei un
pazzo non averci mai giocato chiusa
parentesi avviso parentesi perché stavo
aspettando che uscisse in televisione
melo è grande e dai gem boy del
cellulare di volevo questo nel
visitatore grazie per avermi invitato
sono molto contento si gioca con questo
questo è il gioco con michael merhige la
conosco permette il laccetto che
giochiamo
volevo vedere se rico che io arrivo
dall'alto così erano sapeva cosa può
infatti la prima volta che gioco con
qualcuno volevo vedere se riusciamo a
battere una palestra in due perché non
ho mai giocato in due appunto a poco
quindi volevo vedere come funziona a
giochiamo in due temi la crew e il fai
un simon pokémon vai mutu conto su di te
ma era una seduta al suo sciamu ai new
yorl altro è il mio mio sera spiegano in
una lotta con la lotta tuscia in quattro
mosse da fare ok perché sono psichico
ripresa amnesia cometa che sono le mie
psico che io io vado adesso tocca a te
vai lo slot per telefono bomba sì perché
lui è acquatico cui non uso la roba di
idro fuoco bomba i the lowest uomo
merita un sacco dalla vita
vai pensato io uso psi in teoria lo
batto già io quindi non è servita a
niente
quello già battuto diciamo che io non
uso virtù siamo nati proprio io lo fu a
nato in faccia ora che potenza
io li ho messo tutto in un colpo solo
hai visto come si combatte hai visto
come si cammina ho visto come si vince
ai vistosi vince ma io vorrei farti
vedere altre due cose la prima è la
prima come si catturano i pokémon allora
tu che sei esperto di pokemon tutti gli
altri pokémon li cattura via andando nel
derby e poi sarà il combattimento
adesso non è più così poco non li vedi
li vedi proprio che chigi mai li vedo
che vanno in giro a questi è quindi
niente ressa ti faccio vedere a trans
non puoi catturarlo in due o che fa così
non ci credo hai centrato preciso
incredibile mai preciso il coso e
l'incredibile paolo ci credo è bravo la
fortuna del principiante però è
precisissimo cioè io ho mirato e perché
allora tu praticamente quando che ti
dico che non puoi andare al centro si è
dato poi farei mai una strategia anche
due le tattici si sia hanno fatto poi il
partito non è molto più figo di prima
c'è chi li tattici di puoi fare per
catturare i pokémon la palla curva molto
molto bravo complimenti mi sei piaciuto
mi stringe la mano signora c'è il
bravissimo e volevo partire un'altra
roba che puoi fare un sacco di roba in
pokémon adesso mi sta seguendo ad
esempio 21 da sé da quando ha iniziato a
giocare perché mi eseguito poi fatta so
far uscire gli altri pokémon che adesso
posso far uscire da plos viene però c'è
ancora la cosa più [ __ ] quando tu
finisci il gioco dovete finire gioco
questa roba puoi cavalcare charis hard
ora conte quanto è bello quando il fai
uscire dal cielo cavalli tu vai stop a
voli poi solcare i cieli
innanzitutto si velocissimo che ti fa
risparmiare un sacco di tempo
questa è veramente bella questa razza
ritorno invece ciò anche gary dos
provolo far chiedere questa cosa ma
edizione
wow è stato va in giro e non so se ti
beccano torino perché ho già spiegato e
questo è fare surf su un pokémon cos'era
è un po guerra o guerra non sapevo
potessi tro io che voglio fare dei bei
tiri aspetta è piaciuto il suo tiro
tattico a curvare quello stato un pg ott
e rarissimo ti porta fortuna è no ma
deve dare le bacche per però deve volare
la cattura e scegli la questa la paura
di scegliere mangiare le barche questo
ha capito perché senza aver mai a dalla
banca è andato
allora chi adesso si trasferisca un
podio anche il secondo me ti piace un
sacco da poche mongola pokemon l'esito
pikachu 2 pokémon trasferendo uno di
questi quello che secondo me quello che
ti dia allora proverò a indovinare ai
fan fest ricerca in 13 incontri che sei
si trasferisce paga un gol
vogliamo ne va ok il sacco legamento
adesso dovrebbe prender meli questi due
catturati nel
nel secondo tempo fa adesso sempre
qualche filo così il telefono non ho mai
fatto di favini perché non vai a
trovarli in attimi ha mai fatto ma
pokémon go park
adesso io ho visto che sono due tutti
questi due devi dirmi secondo il secondo
te qual è quello che ho immaginato
perché questo non è il tuo pokémon
ideale ideale
eccolo 21 e l'altro è questo è it non li
e perché dovrebbe essere il mio pokémon
innanzitutto come paese perché questi
due anni ha visto l'altro non hai fatto
reaction parte che smette di spingere
questa hit moll iitm only è che si
chiama così perché è un pokemon lotta e
hanno fatto gli han dato il nome di
bruce lee a figo tipo e catturare
volendo essi così però mi fa provare la
propria board ma che figo è incredibile
non lo sapevo 1000p punti lotta milio te
e tu e prendi operò dai che la presto
tra i pro laccetto pronto
questo è il tuo cuore batte aspetta e i
lanci detto che posso farli anche belli
belli furbi se tipo che il baseball è
scusato il patto che accelerazione se
non lancio per no schiaccia ancora una
volta li fa preparati e ora voi
lanciarmi guardano meno lancio è fai
significato gravissimo assai 6 centrato
dice che sarebbe stata incredibile al
senato perfect io non ci credo è
impossibile questa cosa direbbe ma
voglio capire l'amore che succede te lo
fa catturare l'amica lo permette di
squadra e si e no ma scusami andrai la
roba che trovano in poche comunque
volumetto qua e si e qual è l'attività
dell'indiana logica non dico io che non
lo so mai prova laccetto laccetto ho
trasferito 6 milioni di pokémon ospiti
tutti e 50 quelli che potevano
trasferire per riempire la zona guaio
messi tutti che ser i miei poche o più
forti di pokemon gol così non ce l'ho
più in poi un goccio di acqua ma che
sono veramente tantissimi non ho mai
visto così tanti po con orari tra
l'altro di aziende tra tutti questi
rischi mirate ai più forti di tutti è
l'area che farebbe l'evoluzione del
protagonista di pokemon lesmo libica
l'album è e c'era eccello andiamo per
vino
l'areo questo è fortissimo perché non ce
lo annuncia avevo proprio id quindi non
è anche fare un loro capiscono livello
più rogo devo dire la chiesa è una
ventata il guadagno strana che non
pensavo salis olivelli miei poco non
sense cattura vi nella zona del par
delle barche bravo è imparato è figo
obiettivamente complimenti quindi
ragazzi spero che mi sia piaciuto e
direi che possiamo chiudere cosa ma l
aiuto a me anche piaciuto abbiamo
battuto la palestra varie voluto farti
vedere un master premier però va bene
sono stati proprio questo gli allenatori
con i più forti e più forti bravi a
credibile come possiamo perché anche su
stupido è comunque detto ciò è comunque
in meno fare i complimenti davanti a
tutti che i miei lancer spaccate ho
vinto cioè essere incredibile stanno
l'avesse vista non ci avrei creduto e
abbiamo spero capiti per i ragazzi non
senso che conosciamo come mi piace anche
vari social questa descrizione sono
esistite
ci vediamo ad un prossimo pica cioè una
prossima palestra no no niente
telecomando la propria colpa gol
[Musica]
tutti adesso mentre sto giocando
non ho bisogno di amici
[Musica]